it's that time of month again when
netflix announces all the arrivals
hitting its library
and all the content soon flying off its
shelves let's look at the noteworthy
operatings hitting the netflix catalog
throughout october 2020.
the action and sci-fi selections coming
to netflix in october 2020 are perhaps a
bit more slight than usual but they
certainly contain a few gems
on the first of the month you'll be able
to catch nicholas cage in one of his
most wonderfully over-the-top
performances as johnny blaze the stunt
performer turned spirit of vengeance in
2007's ghost rider
[Music]
also on tap on the first is 2006's
superman returns
the direct belated sequel to richard
donner's superman films with brandon
routh capably taking over for the late
christopher reeve as big blue
other selections available at the
beginning of the month include 2006's
poseidon a modern reworking of the
classic disaster movie the poseidon
adventure
and 1983's war games starring matthew
broderick as a teen computer hacker who
inadvertently sets in motion events that
could lead to world war 3.
later in the month you can catch the
underrated thriller colombiana as well
as dc entertainment's animated
adaptation of batman the killing joke
while there isn't an avalanche of horror
thriller flicks set to hit netflix on
october 2020 there
are a few stone cold classics along with
an intriguing netflix original joining
the catalog
on october 1st catch a trifecta of
awesomeness from directors known for
their visual panache
martin scorsese's cape fear the coen
brothers fargo and the debut flick from
rob zombie house of a thousand corpses
other films in the genre arriving on
netflix on the first of the month are
director paul verhoeven's lurid basic
instinct
and the star-studded 2018 thriller we
have always lived in a castle
on october 16th horror fans can treat
themselves to one of the best
frightflicks of the last decade
2014's unfriended which pioneered the
found footage sub-genre known as
screenlight in which the entire film
takes place within the confines of a
computer screen
finally on the 21st you can check out
the netflix original rebecca which stars
lily james as a newly married woman
struggling with the memory of her
husband's deceased previous wife
if you need a vibe check after going on
a horror movie binge you'll find lots of
new comedy options arriving on netflix
on october 2020
but that doesn't mean you need to stray
far from the halloween themes
adam sandler has a new netflix original
film arriving on october 7th entitled
huby halloween
in this outing sandler plays a bumbling
man trying to convince his community
that on this halloween the monsters
coming out to prowl are very real and
very dangerous
netflix also has a ton of classic
comedic offerings arriving at the
beginning of the month on october 1st
you can see burt reynolds in his prime
in the sports comedy the longest yard
enjoy some royal escapism with the
prince in me
and check out taika waititi's acclaimed
new zealand said adventure hunt for the
wilder people
stand up comedy performances came to a
standstill this year and that means an
uncharacteristic lack of new stand-up
comedy specials from netflix
still necessity breeds innovation and
comedy legend bert kreischer is all set
to release the cabin on october 13th
it's not a stand-up special but it is
still special a mini docu-series
featuring five episodes of ups and downs
as the comedian and his friends attend a
purifying retreat at a cabin in the
woods
netflix's october 2020 drama editions
are a solid mix of must-see classics
exciting new productions and movies that
will broaden
your horizons on october 1st oscar
winning film her is available to stream
along with meta fiction crowd pleaser
stranger than fiction and clint
eastwood's gran torino
on the second of the month get a taste
of what nollywood has to offer with the
gritty nigerian crime drama olo
tour later in the month on october 16th
aaron sorkin's latest movie the trial of
the chicago 7 will premiere on netflix
the movie is a historic drama about a
group of vietnam war protesters who were
charged with inciting riots at the 1968
democratic national
convention netflix also slipped a
christmas movie into its drama
selections for next month
todd haynes's oscar-nominated 1950 set
drama carol arrives on the streamer on
october 20th
to celebrate hispanic heritage month
check out i'm leaving now on october 1st
the film is an intimate portrait of a
mexican immigrant making plans to leave
his adopted home of brooklyn and return
to his family
guillermo v los settling the score a
deep dive into the life and career of
argentinian tennis pro guillermo vilas
hits netflix on october 27th
if documentaries centered on mainstream
celebs or more your speed you can get an
intimate look at one of country music's
most legendary voices in dolly parton
here i am which will arrive on the
streamer on october 6th
or spend time with one of the biggest
bands bringing k-pop to the world and
black pink light up the sky
which drops on october 14th completely
switching gears if you've cherished
listening to david attenborough teach
you about the wonders of the natural
world
learn a little more about the man behind
planet earth with david attenborough
a life on our planet set to join
netflix's library on october 4th
fans of enigmatic international landmark
heist will be happy to hear that the
rebooted carmen san diego is
globetrotting into its third season
starting october 1st
children's program the worst witch
returns the same day for season four
along with all five seasons of monique's
early 2000s sitcom the parkers
if eight movies and a spin-off weren't
enough to keep your engine rumbling fast
and furious spy racer season 2 rio is
hitting the nos button and speeds into
netflix on october 9th the new season
will send the show's heroes to south
america following the disappearance of
one of their own
after all you don't turn your back on
family
even when they do the team might have
relief with the help of another of
netflix's october releases unsolved
mysteries vol
2 coming out october 19th two days after
that david letterman's my next guest
needs no introduction returns
featuring interviews with dave chappelle
robert downing jr and more perhaps the
most exciting piece of tv content coming
to netflix on october 2020 is the sixth
and final season of shit's creek which
swept seven main comedy categories in
all four comedy acting categories at the
2020 emmys at the end of september
the last chapter of the rose family's
richest dirac story will be available to
stream starting on october 7th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one